Are you ready to learn common
expressions, figures of speech,
and connected speech in English?
Let's have a lot of fun doing it today
with popular song, 'Sucker' by the Jonas Brothers.
So this is a fantastic song for you to study with.
It has a lot of figures of speech, and while these are not so common for your spoken English,
they are very present in songs and other similar media,
and, so, it's really good practice
for you to be able to recognize these,
and learn to decipher their meaning.
Plus you'll get a ton of very common American pronunciation examples.
So, let's watch that, and by the way,
if you want to understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles,
we help you to do it every single week,
so, hit that Subscribe button
and the little bell down below
to not miss a single one of our new lessons.
Do you know what a figure of speech is?
Figures of speech are an element of the language
that is very common in music.
Check out this quick explanation that
we gave in another one of our videos.
I highly recommend you check out
that full lesson from Game of Thrones
after you finished this lesson
with the Jonas Brothers.
And, by the way, remember that expressions are
a type of figures speech that are common
in spoken English. However, many figures
of speech, such as the example here
are more for poetic imagery, and are not so
common in spoken English.
But, don't worry because we are going to
be pointing out to you
the most common spoken expressions
throughout this video.
If you're enjoying this lesson,
then you probably will really
love learning English with TV series
with our FREE Mini-Course.
You can learn more, and sign up right up here.
Do you love music?
Then you will definitely want to check out
this playlist with all of our lessons
teaching you English with Music
after you finish this lesson.
You'll find that up here or down in the description below.
Aww yeah! Great job today!
I hope you had a lot of fun with that song!
Be sure to go download it, and listen to it,
and sing along with it so that you can
practice your English everywhere.
And, be sure to hit the Subscribe button so you
can get our newest lessons like this one
every single week!
Check out that FREE Mini-Course I told you about,
and you will definitely want to check out our playlist
with lessons teaching you with songs!
And, finally, this other lesson
that I think you'll really enjoy.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww yeah!